If you happen to run across one of these
interesting little tools, you might
scratch your head at first.
What is it?
This double ended latched tool is
also known as the seed stitch tool.
Now, seed stitch in the US consists of
alternating knit and purl stitches across
each row and alternating rows.
I understand this is called Moss
stitch and other parts of the world.
If you don't use a Brother G-carriage,
anytime machine knitters attempt to
combine, knit and purl stitches
means hand manipulation.
This tool can help to use it.
Drop a single stitch.
Insert the tool in the first
stitch and reform the first stitch.
Next, push the tools so the stitch
rests on the opposite end of the tool.
And use the hook on this end to catch
the next strand in the ladder and form a
stitch in the opposite direction.
Continue up the ladder, back and forth,
back and forth, creating alternate knit
and purl stitches.
You'll repeat this across the entire area
of seed stitch that you want to work.
Now you might find it easier to remove the
work from the machine onto waste yarn and
then reform the stitches off the machine.
Try it both ways.
See which is easier for you.
I don't know about you, but I certainly
don't have the patience to create large
amounts of seed stitch.
I'll pick up my hand knitting needles
first, but a little bit of seeds ditch
here and there may just be the designer
touch you're looking for, and this little
tool is a boon for getting that done.